a
[Música]
ah
pero espera contar con la vacuna contra
el kobe 19 a fines de diciembre los
primeros días de enero el presidente
francisco sagasti ha anunciado que a
fines de enero marzo los primeros días
de abril se vacunar a la población más
vulnerable la estrategia es inmunizar
antes de las elecciones presidenciales
del 2021 pero ha cerrado un acuerdo de
118 millones de dólares con laboratorio
fighter iv' hay un tec por 16 millones
de vacunas que solo cubren a la mitad de
los 32 millones de peruanos pero algunos
especialistas sostienen que la vacuna
arriba en diciembre al país solamente un
millón de peruanos podrían ser vacunados
en el primer trimestre del 2021 y
pronostican que no será posible vacunar
a 24 millones de ciudadanos antes de los
comicios tal como lo tenían programado
las autoridades el decano del colegio
médico del perú miguel palacios afirmó
que el anuncio del presidente francisco
sagasti en realidad es para 50.000 dosis
que el laboratorio facer otorgará dentro
de un plan piloto y posteriormente
llegará un lote de un millón y medio de
vacunas que servirán para 750.000
personas entre enero y abril de 2021
[Música]
el gobierno boliviano ha anunciado la
adquisición de 3 millones de dosis de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 las que se
distribuirán de manera gratuita al
personal sanitario está en la primera
línea de la lucha contra la enfermedad y
también a las personas vulnerables ha
señalado que un total de 600.000 dosis
estarán en el país en el primer
trimestre del próximo año sin embargo
los médicos consideran que las 3
millones de dosis y no solamente las
600.000 deberían estar disponibles en
primera instancia en bolivia tomando en
cuenta que se teme que la segunda ola de
kobe 19 llegue al país justamente en
marzo del próximo año por otro lado el
gobierno ha anunciado que se hace
gestiones con cuatro laboratorios para
adquirir vacunas para los 11 millones de
habitantes de bolivia sin embargo
todavía no ha informado cuáles son las
empresas con las que se realizan estas
negociaciones el monto que se destinará
o las fechas en que estas vacunas
estarán disponibles en bolivia
[Música]
el gobierno de nicolás maduro ha dicho
que 28 millones de habitantes tienen
garantizados el suministro de 10
millones de dosis de la vacuna ruso
sputnik 5 el gobernante venezolano
estimó además que para el segundo
trimestre de 2021 comenzará la
vacunación de toda la población contra
el jove y 19 sin especificar cuáles
fármacos prevé distribuir aunque ha
insistido que su gobierno también está
articulado con las vacunas que están
siendo desarrolladas en china india y
cuba la vicepresidenta del si rodríguez
también ha anunciado que se elevó al
gobierno de rusia no sólo el
planteamiento de comprar la vacuna
sputnik 5 cuando esté disponible de
forma masiva sino igualmente la
posibilidad de fabricarla en venezuela-
el país caribeño recibe en octubre un
primer lote con 2.000 dosis de la vacuna
y por ahora está participando en la fase
3 del desarrollo del fármaco maduro ha
asegurado que los ensayos van muy bien y
espera dar a conocer los resultados
cuando termine esta fase aunque no
anunció una fecha estimada
[Música]